we've been hacking and slashing at Greek
and sometimes Norse Gods and Monsters in
God of War since 2005. to celebrate the
launch of God of War Ragnarok let's take
a look at the history of the series
[Music]
in 2002 fresh off the release of their
futuristic racing game Connecticut Sony
Santa Monica Studio began working on
something new Connecticut designer David
Jaffe had an idea what if there was a
game that was like onimusha but with
Greek mythology instead of Japanese and
had the frenetic action of Devil May Cry
and the puzzle solving of Eco and then
it also had a bunch of adult themes like
sex and violence sprinkled on top
foreign
god of war and over-the-top hack and
slash game with puzzles and platforming
thrown in for good measure God of War is
our attempt to really Elevate the action
adventure genre to the next level but it
wasn't always called God of War and its
lead character wasn't always called
Kratos throughout development the
working title for the game was Dark
Odyssey and Kratos was Dominus when the
marketing team asked for a new name for
the character the team submitted some
ideas with the front runner actually
being the name Stig a name shared with
the game's lead environment artist Stig
asmussen eventually the team landed on
Kratos a Spartan warrior who makes a
bargain with Ares the god of war and is
indentured into his service the main
character main character Kratos is a
very uh Disturbed character while Waging
War for Aries Kratos is tricked into
killing his wife and daughter and their
ashes are bound to his skin giving him
his ghostly white appearance Kratos vows
revenge against Ares and begins to
search for Pandora's Box to bring down a
God every bit as weak as the day you beg
me to save your life I am not the same
man you found that day
the monster you've created has returned
to kill you as a part of his dodgy deal
Ares binds two blades to kratos's
forearms using chains and these Blades
of chaos are what he uses to wage
destruction against everyone and
everything who gets in his way from Gods
to harpies sirens and Gorgons kratos's
blades swung around and shredded
anything that stood in his path
later in the game he gets magical
abilities and even an additional sword
fleshing out the Arsenal he uses on his
angry man Rampage chaining attacks would
build an ability called Rage of the Gods
which would rip through enemies when
Unleashed lighting up Combos and
smashing through QuickTime events to
defeat foes was equal parts badass
brutal and satisfying and players loved
it if you have a dark sense of humor if
you love the action adventure games if
you don't mind a whole lot of blood and
maybe a little bit of nudity here and
there this is the game for you God of
War launched for the PlayStation 2 to
critical Acclaim earning a 94 Metacritic
score with the only real sticking point
being the game's static camera movie
rights were snapped up but as of this
video no firm release is in sight
however a new Amazon Prime streaming
Series has been announced
foreign
Kratos becomes the God of War but is
still haunted by his past deeds and the
loss of his family after joining the
Spartan Army to attack the city of
Rhodes Zeus betrays him strips him of
his power and he's taken it to the
underworld Kratos hunts down the sisters
of Fates who have the ability to turn
back time a feat that he wants to use to
help him get revenge obviously with new
weapons relics and abilities Kratos
takes the fight to Zeus battling any
creature God and even Kraken who once
again is foolish enough to stand in his
way after directing the original God of
War David Jaffe became the creative
director of its sequel with lead
animator Corey barlog stepping into
direct and this won't be the last you'll
hear about one Mr barlog we're here for
the the Sony Playstation Store Metreon
midnight launch event God that's a
mouthful and it is freaking awesome to
be done with this thing God of War 2
launched in early 2007 for the
PlayStation 2 mere months after Sony's
shiny and expensive new PlayStation 3
was set to launch when asked why it
didn't launch on PS3 balog referenced
the 100 million ps2s that had already
been sold that people could play the
game on while also saying that PS3
owners could play it via backwards
compatibility Remember When PS3 could
actually play PS2 games backwards
compatibility what a concept the game's
launch was once again incredibly
successful both critically and
commercially with gamespot's review from
Alex Navarro saying that it's more
brutal and more focused than its
predecessor and that it's hard to
imagine a better swan song for the PS2
it's frequently lauded as one of the
best PS2 games of all time and to
Corey's point about the PS3 the game was
eventually remastered and released for
the console sometime after backwards
compatibility was removed from the
PlayStation 3.
in 2007 Kratos made his mom mobile game
debut in God of War betrayal set between
god of war and God of War 2 Kratos is
you guessed it betrayed and he has to
hunt down the mysterious stranger who
has it in for him in this 2D side
scroller Hack and Slash
[Music]
the following year another spin-off
emerged on handheld platforms this time
the PSP chains of Olympus was developed
by Sony Santa Monica and ready at dawn
who would eventually go on to make the
order 1886. chains of Olympus is a
prequel to God of War where the
dreamlord Morpheus has put a number of
the Gods to sleep and Kratos is tasked
with putting a stop to his scheming but
when the promise of being reunited with
his daughter is dangled in front of him
he has to decide where his loyalties lie
God of War's epic battles and gory
combos translated exceptionally well to
the handheld PSP console and the game is
still the highest rated PSP game of all
time according to Metacritic
foreign
Kratos leapt onto the PlayStation 3 with
God of War 3 in an epic opening sequence
Kratos and the Titans scale Mount
Olympus to take out the gods once and
for all naturally it doesn't all go to
plan and Kratos is betrayed again this
time by the Titan Gaia who sends Kratos
back to the Underworld the original
ending plan for the game was actually
very very different to what we ended up
with I'll let the series original
Creator David Jaffe who had left Sony at
this point explain you kill Zeus in the
first couple of minutes God of War 3
there's a vacuum on Earth because that
the Greek mythology religion is in
shambles the other religions and gods
Russia and Norse mythology Egyptian
mythology to kind of take over that that
place now that Zeus is no longer a power
he ends up getting all the gods to fight
amongst themselves thus ignoring man on
earth and the way Kratos realizes that
you kill Gods with finality is that you
get people to stop believing in them so
as the gods have ignored man man begins
to turn away from the gods and that's
how Kratos kills all of the Gods the God
of War 3 ending we got was as I
mentioned very different with Kratos
utilizing the power of Hope from
Pandora's Box to eventually overpower
the gods of Olympus before giving the
power to mankind Kratos impales himself
on his own sword hoping to die and
reunite with his family once and for all
the reviews for God of War 3 were
glowing and upon release it was selling
more quickly than its predecessor dear
PlayStation I know in God of War 3
you're this Kratos guy seeking Vengeance
against the guards but since my
boyfriend got it he's been totally
ignoring me its sales were driven by an
intense marketing campaign that included
a contest to find the ultimate God of
War fan and even a themed NASCAR vehicle
but that wouldn't be the last we'd see
of Kratos or the Greek gods by unlocking
the platinum trophy in God of War 3
players would be given a link to a
website called Spartans Stand Tall when
enough people had unlocked the trophy a
new game in the series was teased
okay
God of War ghost of Sparta launched on
the PSP in late 2010 with an important
story set between God of War 1 and 2
where Kratos heads to Atlantis and is
tasked by his dying mother to find his
presumed Dead Brother Deimos man Kratos
cannot catch a break when it comes to
family matters huh while the game didn't
review quite as well as the others with
many critics lamenting that it was just
more of the same and didn't push the
boundaries of the franchise it was
praised for its visuals and just how
well it handled on the PSP
[Applause]
in 2013 we found out just how Kratos
became so angry with the release of God
of War ascension a prequel to the entire
series that was set 10 years before the
events of the original game it follows
Kratos after he breaks his oath to serve
Ares and is hunted by the furies
although not technically another quest
for Revenge it still involves Kratos
trying to break the chains of servitude
by killing a lot of things the game's
distinguishing feature was that it
introduced multiplayer to the series for
the first time allowing up to eight
players to battle it out online in a
number of modes favor of the Gods as you
reach a certain amount of favor points
by killing others and controlling zones
on the map and trial of the Gods is a
co-op wave-based survival mode the
multiplayer didn't blow anyone away and
was criticized for lacking depth
Ascension reviewed pretty well but it
was clear that the franchise needed a
breath of fresh air Olympus was old news
and fans were waiting for what was next
for Kratos after a few years working on
various projects including a stint with
Mad Max director George Miller and
working on 2013's Tomb Raider Corey
barlag returned to Sony Santa Monica to
helm the next installment of the God of
War franchise with Olympus seemingly
played out it was time for Kratos to
find a new home away from the drama of
the Greek gods
[Music]
during development ancient Egypt was
considered as a setting for the game
with the team even creating concept art
but the team at Sony Santa Monica
eventually settled on Norse mythology
with the isolation and Barren nature of
the land being appealing after the
events of God of War 3 Kratos leaves
Greece and ends up in Scandinavia
marries a woman named Faye and has a son
atreus but Kratos isn't able to escape
his bloody past quite so easily and
despite living a quiet life he catches
the attention of the Norse gods after
Faye's death Kratos and atreus journeyed
to the highest peak in the Realms to
scatter her ashes while being pursued by
balder the son of Odin the game centers
around kratos's struggle to break the
cycle of violence and his relationship
with his son who is unknowingly part god
I know you're a God
not of this realm but there's no
mistaking it
[Music]
it's a no does he not only did the game
take a moment emotional approach to
storytelling but its gameplay was
markedly different to previous entries
in a number of ways the camera was no
longer fixed instead following Kratos in
one continuous camera shot with clever
tricks used to hide loading screens gone
with kratos's iconic blades at least at
the beginning of the game replaced by
the Leviathan ax an ice imbued weapon
that you could throw and recall with the
satisfying press of a button much like
Thor's hammer mjolnir the game was far
from an escort Mission with atreus
proving useful not only when solving
puzzles by helpfully offering
suggestions but he could hold his own in
combat by filling enemy stun meters with
his bow and arrow even summoning
spectral animals to help fight God of
War was a critical and Commercial
Success earning High review scores and
winning multiple Game of the Year Awards
alright and the game award for game of
the year goes to God of War
Corey Ballard released an emotional
video of him seeing the 94 Metacritic
score for the first time which honestly
is a real really lovely watch
but that wasn't the only God of War
title to launch in 2018 because there
was also Mimi's Vision an AR experience
for IOS and Android that would beam the
game's map onto a flat surface and let
you poke around in it and learn about
the realm of midgard if you're into that
kind of stuff there was also a call from
the Wilds a text Adventure game on
Facebook Messenger where you play as
atreus on his first Adventure if you
make it to the end you'll unlock eight
pieces of art from God of War as of 2022
it sadly seems that call from the Wilds
isn't working anymore this brings us to
God of War Ragnarok Ragnarok aka the end
of the world in Norse mythology is
coming and Kratos and atreus are trying
to stop it a daunting task made even
more difficult by the Asia Gods Odin
Freya and Thor who are seeking Revenge
from the deaths of their kin Ragnarok
will be the end of the north Saga for
Kratos and atreus with the creative team
at Sony Santa Monica revealing that due
to the long development process they
didn't want to stretch the story out for
years and felt that two games were
enough to conclude it for more on God of
War Ragnarok including our review
features and guides make sure to
subscribe to Gamespot on YouTube and
check out gamespot.com we'll also have
more episodes of history of coming your
way thank you so much for watching you
can find me on Twitter at Lucy James
games and we'll see you next time